the topic for our discussion is faith
and globalization but what do we mean by
faith and what do we mean by
globalization how do we understand faith
in the world today well we use faith in
plural we mean multiple faiths and we
use faith in plural in order to signal
that we are not interested in some
abstraction called faith but rather in
concrete religious traditions we're
interested in how people are shaped by
these traditions how people to say it in
this way inhabit those traditions how
these traditions shaped concrete lives
of people of course we are also
interested in kind of diffuse forms of
religiosity but sometimes people
describe as smorgasbord religiosity
especially appearing in the Western
countries that too is a force that
shapes people's lives so that's how we
will treat the term faith we will also
explore what is the best way to
understand the processes of
globalization now this is a very
contested field and many theories of
globalization's are in play we will
discuss those various theories and try
to find appropriate ways and through
which to access that very complex
phenomenon and indeed because both
faiths and globalization processes are
such complex phenomena we will attend to
the interdisciplinary character of the
search to understand these phenomena
faith and also globalization this is the
place where scholars from various
disciplines and fields can come together
and look at the phenomenon that shape
the world today in a conversational way
mutually enriching each other's
perspective